our new president has identified as one
of his three major areas of attention
health care which by the way I
personally applaud and and Mao has
worked through its Health Policy
Institute to articulate the four pillars
that are necessary for transforming
healthcare and those four pillars then
provide the the environment with which
the center for innovation and innovation
across the country in healthcare
delivery can can evolve and and and
those pillars are pretty simple
conceptually they include creating value
coordinating care restructuring the
payment system and providing universal
access those are the four pillars now
for the the innovations that we envision
helping to catalyze through our Center
activities to be maximally effective
there needs to be policy changes that
address those four areas care
coordination value payment reform and
universal access
if you're in charge of a delivery system
and you're being reimbursed because of
the quality or value of the care that
you provide and because of the
coordination that you provide rather
than on the number of tests that are
done then that provides a whole
different set of incentives for you to
reorganize the way you deliver health
care right now the and this gets back to
one of the four pillars of our of our
policy initiative and that is payment
reform right now the payment system
results in just what you expected it to
do and that is if you pay people to do
if if people get paid because they do a
lot of stuff they're going to keep doing
more and more stuff to get more to get
more and more pay but if you pay people
for the quality of what they deliver and
you define quality or value and you have
metrics for value and you make those
metrics publicly available so the
consumer knows where to go to get the
highest value care and you coordinate
you